hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a house flipper this game
a is a little old at this point
in fact I bought it about when it first
came out and I've never played it since
in fact I know very little about how the
game is played considering how long it's
been out I've seen it I know the concept
I'm not I know you buy a house and you
flip it and I used to work as a
carpenter building decks so I think I
will be goodly equipped to handle the
challenges that this game is going to
present to me so I think I think that
unless there's some secret twist into
this game that's like super scary and
subtle which it would be almost the
perfect game for it I think I'm going to
approach this calmly logically and
absolutely try to make this house the
best house that I could ever flip
because I've thought about that in the
back before I became a youtuber I was
like my boss and the deck building
business was like yeah I thought about
just over a winter because not many
people buy decks in the winter you could
just buy a house and then spend the
whole winter fixing it up and go in on
then I was like oh yeah sure I'd love
that anyway what a mess I need to clean
this up did I just buy this property did
I buy this [ __ ] Shack did I legitimately
look at this [ __ ] Shack as an investment
property look at the house to yard ratio
I mean it's nice but this is a Sims
house this is legitimately like baby's
first Sims house okay whatever dispose
dispose at least it just goes away at
least I don't have to walk into the curb
check the emails on my love this is my
house I didn't even flip this what god
damn hope do I have to make a profit
flipping houses if this is my house oh
my god I was cleaning up was this easy
oh my god oh it's so bad please put it
in the sink Oh put it in the sink put it
in the sink ah God just put it a stop oh
my god
don't even have a reflection okay if the
laptop will allow you to find jobs buy
houses and switch between them you
cannot afford to buy a house yet but it
looks like you already have your first
email who is contacting me who did i
trick into thinking that I was a good
handyman who the hell would trust me to
do anything Jesus
okay anyway my shock is over didn't get
over it getting over it I'm over it all
right Sarah Luis ex-boyfriend stole the
radiator from my house do I have to run
a hit job what did they do I have to
kill this guy do I have to break his
knees to stop I'd like to hire your
company to put my house in order I know
from photos posted on face spam that my
ex-boyfriend broke into my house made a
huge best and stole the radiator it is
possible that something else is missing
please make order in the house and
replace the missing devices I would ask
you not to inform the police about the
whole matter I will settle it myself
with my ex-boyfriend after returning
from a business trip there is gonna be
some dark secret subplot to this game
Gunn amount one knot I was joking I was
joking about there being a dark subgun
quantity one not enough what honey guns
you need all right whatever
congratulations you unlock new tool from
now on you'll be able to clean dirty
stuff using the mop yeah
all right just gonna let me in this
house huh you sure do trust who all
right clean sure no sound associated
with it but yeah just slap the mop on
the walls that's that's how I clean up
my messes I'm not a hundred percent sure
how these walls got like this but
frankly I guess I shouldn't question it
oh my god I just cleaned this [ __ ]
stained couch what happened did you live
here with your ex-boyfriend you're on a
business trip
what business what what business okay
let me just get rid of the trash first
because that's just a nightmare by
itself get trash trash
the radiator is indeed gone you have a
tablet your disposal press tab to use or
hide it allows you to buy things it'll
be handy for this task yeah why am i
buying them a radiator I guess because I
can build them for it I searched for a
radiator here we go all right um sure
right there sounds great oh I actually
have to assemble it oh [ __ ] oh oh oh
satis facto oh that's nice oh that's
actually nice oh that's really nice
Hey look at that
no no no no this this place is a
nightmare I am NOT I am NOT leaving it
like this there is no way now am i
leaving this place like this holy crap
this is bad okay open these stains why
don't you have sheets turn on the tablet
and choose what point you want to spend
a new skill on skill penetrating vision
I'm gonna [ __ ] penetrate some vision
you don't even need to tell me twice
about what I need to pick I am
penetrating period take it a picture I
don't know why maybe it approved of the
client just to shame them of how
disgusting this place is alright why do
you need so many goddamn radiators ok
there's a spot in the kitchen here that
I missed so oh wait this garbage got
that alright that's good open up here
that's disgusting
alright good that that okay hundred
percent baby why is that there I have no
idea
alright we're gonna put that right by
here there's should that should still
close yep
so we're good there bathtubs good
toilets good that's good that's good
this is looking ok let's get this
straightened out
oh my god the whole thing is wrong let's
tuck it so that's accessible on the side
but not too much
let's bring the center to that spot got
you no other game actually meticulous
about this [ __ ] I do not know why I'm
this way here I really don't know this
is not like me in any way
I mean legitimately this is not this is
not me
glad yet Here I am this doesn't make
sense here because there's not a lot of
space hmm this is just a very sincere
lack of space going on here
why am I thinking about this so
intensely yeah I think that's gonna do
close the doors on the wind house the
backyard well I don't need to worry
about mowing that's for damn sure
Plus that up this looks pretty good let
me see what it looks like all right um
yeah that's about as good as I could
hope that this was oddly satisfying
I enjoyed this way too much and this is
a really nice little space they got here
it's basically just like all you need
this has got that HT HGTV vibe doesn't
it it feels like one of those shows that
you just like you really love the
process and there's something very
satisfying about the end result I get it
I didn't think that I was the type of
person to appreciate it but looks like I
am okay I think I'm done complete the
order completed food it's enough to
survive oh my god thank God I could
afford a mop oh lordy loo oh thank God I
got penetrating vision oh the ceiling oh
my god
it's awful Oh guys also horrible
oh these cabinets suck they're all
broken
oh this bathroom is awful this is so
horrible
how did I ever survive all right I need
to get over it I'm not gonna get through
this game if this is like the worst I've
ever seen oh my god
I guess I'll put that up now even square
anymore broken mirror jeez the outside I
mean it's just it's a freaking shed
it's a rusted-out disgusting old shed I
guess I must have bought it but why was
my laptop already in here that's
indicative that I've been here a while
got that got that okay just one more in
like the bathroom area oh there yep okay
thank goodness my freaking house is at
least livable whoo all right what do we
got mail radiators I will pay you if I
am fully satisfied or you get nothing
winter is coming the winters are hard
and there are no radiators in my house
mount them expensive stuff modernity ah
modernity okay great
baby all right
this at least it's not a disgusting
nightmare that's the one thing that I'm
pretty happy with it's not a disgusting
nightmare okay
store or radiator by for some reason
people just don't have radiators in this
building you're in this neighborhood or
in this life or in this world in this
world there are no such things as
radiators this is oddly satisfying I I
do have to admit something about this
very nice very very nice okay handyman
ooh ooh
well right now I'm mounting and I've
always wanted to get better at mounting
in general I think I've got to go with
the numb
in bonus I would definitely like to get
better and mounting that wouldn't want
the baby to get cold here put that bad
boy on there oh that is much better
look at the speed this is most
indubitably the good choice that's a
good stuff
perfect perfect perfect what do we have
here
can buy a sink towel radiator towel
radiator mountable towel radiator Oh
interesting
yeah I've seen these before it's like a
full-on IKEA simulator thing this is
nice this lovely man I wish it was this
easy to install stuff in my home I just
put in a some blinds for my window and I
ended up breaking off the drill bit into
the wall and then I just had to drive a
screw up in there and kind of just like
push it up to the other side so yeah I
didn't really um I didn't really do that
very well oh my god HDTV what the [ __ ]
it is HGTV I didn't know that oh my god
it does have the HGTV vibe because it is
oh my god I just came sponsored by HGTV
find and unscrew the cap oh that makes
sense
interesting all right okay I don't know
what I just did
oh right okay washer nut washer nut this
thing that thing this thing clunk that
screw this thing plunk
this thing plunk screw this thing that
the faucet the handle the drain the
drain the drain the the drain the drain
the drain the drain well looks like I'm
gonna get better at mounting that's
literally the only thing I care about
excellent everything's in order better
close the front door what a beautiful
home what a lovely baby room the walls
should be immaculate who are you talking
to I don't know what you're talking
about yeah you can take pictures great
that's that's great
why would I do raid eater in my own
place is the question am I eventually
gonna be able to sell this place is that
the lesson that I need to learn here is
that eventually I need to sell Oh option
negotiate price nice 10% extra payment
well I mean that seems like the best
base thing right just 10% more money
[Music]
I'm gonna move the bed okay so I'm
putting a radiator in my place in the
hopes it's gonna increase the value
eventually I'm guessing that's the point
all of this is like a tutorial that
teach you all the stuff that you could
do eventually to get your own place in
order god I'm strong
goddess God is strong I am so strong by
the gods look at my strength Wow
all right there we go that's nice wow
that's nice well that's lovely it's very
lovely what else can I do
oh sink that's right wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait there was
something in here that I can do a towel
radiator yes yes yes perfect good thing
I'm so fast at this perfect wait where'd
that third splott come from when did
this get dirty who came over and shat on
the side of my house who the hell did
this Oh kind of realism of this so I
gotta do maintenance on my house I'll
give right okay all right yes sure who
stained up my house all right looking
better hopefully this thing is worth a
little more now how in depth does this
game go how deep is this baby on the way
my beautiful wife is pregnant with our
first child we have also just bought a
new 3-bedroom home which requires some
repairs and decorating we have no spare
time to clean reven evade the house so
we need your help can you please clean
the house and set up a nursery complete
with crib changing table and maybe some
toys we know we will have a girl so can
you please paint the room light pink yes
please teach me how to paint a lot of
toys at home means a lot of fun please
tell me that's not the baby's house with
all those horriffic things paint the
walls cool
I can oh my god don't look at the
mini-map guys don't look at the mini-map
it's horrible oh my god oh my god you
know if they're supposed to clean it
when you buy it you know that right holy
[ __ ] oh my god what happened
yeah god I just need faster cleaning
because I can't do it what do you mean
see some dirt on the minimap
you mean I'm not seeing it all oh my god
I'm not seeing it all what have you done
at least there's a radiator God the one
thing I know how to do is not as a
radiator why is there no sound effect
the mopping either gonna slapping a
toothbrush over on the walls there
[Music]
clean the window Oh interesting Oh
interesting I didn't know that this was
a separate thing I thought my mop was a
one mop all kind of deal oh this is
satisfying oh that is very satisfying oh
that's very nice oh this is lovely oh I
see why people love this game I oh I
definitely can see that oh my goodness I
see that pretty good game pretty good
game guys pretty good game pretty good
game you guys got here a pretty good
game oh my god yes please yes please oh
my god I don't even know what device
this is was a like a hand vac oh it's
amazing oh my god I want one I I have an
anionic smile on my face I don't like
cleaning I really don't I don't know why
I'm enjoying it in a video game I don't
know but I am and it's very lovely but
also I'm very mad at the parents who
bought this
Oh
make the bed yeah that's my job I'm I'm
a maid
that's what I am
[Music]
I think these are smoke stains on the
window there's no way this is just
normal dirt this is a habitual smokers
literal smoke oh my ghoul what is that
that's not smoke the other knows very
clearly smoke this one no way Jose I
gotta go slow on this one all right
good great glad glad glad glad very glad
very glad very glad this is the bathroom
oh god I almost threw up Oh guys guys
guys why is it green oh they don't even
have a mirror oh my god why am i
bothering why why am i bothering this
far beyond a handyman's repertoire good
I better get paid insane for this oh I
am $2,700 [ __ ] okay yeah love to clean I
love cleaning I get paid three thousand
dollars to clean house I ain't gonna be
making YouTube videos anymore that's for
damn sure you catch me good I've been
cleaning for what 30 minutes Jesus all
right give me the mop wanna do a lot of
did it lots of did it needs
[Music]
okay that looks pretty good
except for this windows [ __ ]
disgusting good I think this is going to
be the baby room then let's get to
painting
first and foremost panty panty paint how
do I get paint do I need to buy the
paint first walls pale pink what exact
paint did they want pastel pink of
course of course
all right pink pastel pink by three
[Music]
dabbe oh this is satisfying nice even
coats nice even coats is real nice
[Music]
painting you won't waste paint on an
already painted wall hmm bye say paint
more that's doubling up that's better
boom baby
[Music]
dammit I'm out
hmm guess I need more paint this is I
hate say it very satisfying
[Music]
now I definitely need to get this skill
that's not wasting paint on an already
painted wall because this doubling up
technique is just wasting paint on
already painted walls but I'm faster now
an amateur might neglect to move the
dresser to get the space behind but I am
no amateur ah that is for sure
[Music]
that is a nice-looking room no need to
paint the ceiling because that would
look ridiculous so sell that BAM
oh I didn't know that I could sell this
stuff oh you don't need a dresser do you
I didn't think so
did I just sell their crap can I
actually please tell me I can oh what
the damn it
alright crib crib you got it cribs
apparently this is my job
crib crib get the crib in here right
below that window no right right by the
radiator you want you want a warm baby
you want the warmest baby you could
possibly get this baby's gonna be toasty
all right maybe not maybe not right
there maybe mmm adjacent to the radiator
maybe near by the radiator but tucked
into a corner so it gets a little waft
of the radiation that's what you want
okay Skol interesting interesting I
don't know why it's called that a poof
poof poof sorry who the French I mean
pink and blue or kind of a nice combo
you know I'm selling this [ __ ] we're not
playing thief simulator ah goddamn it I
thought but it doesn't fit but it
doesn't fit the Fung Shui the room
don't worry whatever that's definitely
not gonna go there so let's put this
right here
alright so what this does is it allows
this space to be placed based on the
toys would go in there I guess toys
hanging spiders right above the baby's
bed boink
you know
right above the head there yeah that's
nice
all right um well apparently I don't
have a hundred percent of it completed
not a hundred cents sure why ah
the dirts is not done in this room
that's why well if only I could see it
all with my penetrating vision then
maybe I might have a chance there's one
last piece of dirt somewhere in this
room there's one last speck of dirt
somewhere in this room
and I will find it it cannot ha ha got
it got it perfectly okay so I didn't get
all the dirt in this room oh definitely
did not hey all right on a percent baby
baby baby get in here baby hey baby you
got a house I'm not happy with it but
whatever it's fine
all right good completely order six
thousand dollars oh my lord
one gas mask what are you talking about
so what I need to do is I'm gonna sell
this [ __ ] sell sell sell oh my god sell
sell sell so all of this just needs to
go it just has to go oh my god it's
disgusting it's awful
even this door has to go go get gone get
get get get get get get get that scary
how long I've been home I got I've been
playing this for almost an hour this
game is for some reason very fun and all
I'm doing is cleaning and I don't know
why it's fun but it's it's hardly Fonda
and Selma and Selma get rid of that get
out of here get out of here chainsaw I
don't even know why that's there this
rug sucks no one's welcome this door is
awful so now that it's nice and
bare-bones in here I can actually get
some good [ __ ] I want to fix up my house
first period because for some reason I
live in squalor and I don't like that I
don't like that none at all sell a
shower
hook up I think I need the shower hook
up cuz I need to put a shower in here
mount a bull shower
I don't need a complicated one just need
a very basic [ __ ] one well this looks
complicated weird whoa
I have no idea what I'm doing I'm just
clicking buttons sure yeah okay shove it
shove it in shove it in shove it shove
it in mount it slap it shove it screw it
bop it twist it squeeze it nothing bolt
it slap it slap it slap it in slap it on
slap it around screw it I think I'm
getting it glass it crunch it punch it
punch it punch it slang [ __ ] lunch it
what is that I don't know what I'm
looking at what was I looking at
what am I looking at what about looking
at I have no idea I think this is the
door mechanism but honestly who knows
the nice a shower there's only a hundred
something books
what a deal slap it wrap it yeah yeah
pit dunzo listen I shower okay okay okay
toilet standard old toilet ye old toilet
of old
let's assemble it malted yoked it jolted
faulted all that y'all done Yolo
okay cool mirror now what I don't know
how to do is tile and that's what this
bathroom is in case you're stupid then
weren't able to tell that this is a tile
bathroom and I don't know how to deal
with that Oh door god I don't even play
shower
it's it's a hand shower I hate that door
got door front door slam it in there oh
[Music]
yeah
internal door Brown door if I turn oon
this wood it was this easy
I would not bunk bird yes absolutely
it seems only logical very prison feel
in air but you know feels right at home
you know I don't want to be too far away
from home bedside table
Hermes how about a nice pine nah still
white that's real nice and that way it
can be used by both the ones on the
bottoms and also the ones on the tops
yes it's kind of British in the gap
bringing us closer together you know
what I mean yeah you knows what I'm
talking about
there we go let's get this straightened
out finally bada-bing bada-boom
all right I think we've turned this
house into a home
that will probably do it for this
episode of house flipper I didn't know
what I was getting into I still think
there's a scary subplot but as far as
this game goes it's very fun there's
something very satisfying about just
fixing a place up makes you feel like
everything's gonna be okay you know so
why don't you try polishing off that
given the given the subscribe button to
do scrub you know clean it out a little
bit that Bell needs to be polished so
give it an old rub slap it a few times
hit it with your mop and maybe you'll
see this channel look it fixed right up
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I don't know if I'm gonna do
another one of these unless the game
gets super super crazy and interesting
later on I think
one's enough for me but this is still
fun - thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]